hey guys
a new alien monster movie has just been
released and chris pratt is the lead
role in
a war to save humanity's future well
this would be yet another
alien monster movie of 2021 following
the release of a quiet place part 2.
well spoilers ahead obviously and if you
haven't watched the movie then i suggest
you do
so before checking out this video
warning sent
now let's tell you something about the
movie first it's a sci-fi
action movie that revolves around the
character that is sent to the future to
fight in a losing war for humanity
against an alien invader and these
aliens are called
white spikes they are a swarm species
and they are very difficult to kill
ok origins so let's start with how these
aliens came to earth in the first place
well in the movie the war against these
creatures was set
in the year 2051 and the white spikes
will arrive
in november 2048 and kill the majority
of humanity
in three years time in response to
worlds militaries are sent
into the future by a wormhole device
called the jumbling
by people coming from the future back
into the past but fewer than 30
survived deployment to return in seven
days it was widely believed that in the
future
that these aliens arrived in 2048 but as
we watched a movie
it was discovered that they arrived as
cargo of another alien
spacecraft in the 10th century a.d
they were in fact like biological
weapons of war similar to how the
xenomorphs were made by the engineers to
wipe out a planet species
in prometheus and alien covenant so
let's dive into the aliens themselves
these creatures are very big in size
although not gigantic
they were bigger than humans and seem to
be in the size range of buffaloes or
rhinos
they are very quick and agile and they
can act as a swarm species
with not much of an individual level of
intelligence that is impressive but they
follow orders from a queen
and certain members of a species called
may be termed as
alphas so they function in a way similar
to the xenomorphs of the alien franchise
and also the tom cruise mimics of from
edge of tomorrow
there are a multitude of males in the
swamp but only one
female that was seen and this is very
much like the queen xenomorph
as it is bigger and highly intelligent
as it can track
hunt and execute strategies as well as
combat tactics
so anyway we now shall look at the
design of these white spikes
and to start with both males and females
share a similar anatomy
with the only is that the size is bigger
for the female and also the shape of the
head
they are both white in coloration and
have spikes on their backs which gives
them their name
white spikes these aliens run in a
quadripedal manner
although they have six limbs with two
four limbs two bigger high limbs and two
smaller insectic
limbs situated on the chest like those
of the muta prime
the female muto that can be used as
melee weapons for close quarter combat
the most peculiar thing is the presence
of two prehensile tails that have the
ability to shoot
large dots against enemies from a
distance
the head of these aliens have a large
mouth lined with rows of sharp teeth
and the head as well as the back and
even the entire body is bulletproof
except for the neck and the abdomen
which are termed as their weak points
so what about their powers well the
white sprites can run as fast as
leopards alliance but not as fast as
cheetahs
somewhere in the 60 to 80 kilometers per
hour range
they are agile as they can climb
vertically and puncture concrete
structures with their limbs
which allow them to scale virtually
anything they have a very powerful bite
force as the female shows by biting a
person in half
right in the middle their tails can
shoot dots from long distances and these
dots are huge
with one shot being able to easily
decapitate a human
and they are also seen shooting and
hiding like soldiers in battlefields
which tell us that they have on-ground
battlefield tactics
the alphas and female queen can command
and direct attacks to wherever they wish
to
and one more important power is their
ability to glide seemingly like
flying squirrels but they need a high
ground to launch themselves with
lastly the queen maybe has the ability
to contact
for help telepathically from long
distances of up to hundreds of
kilometers
but these aliens have quite a few
disadvantages firstly is that they are
hyper carnivorous
and they are in a constant state of
hunger which makes their population less
likely to survive
without hibernation and lack of food
they also rest on the seventh day
the sabbath and going back to their
nests in the end of the sixth day
this allows for humans to regroup and
strategize and the main weakness
are the two parts in their body which
are not bulletproof that is their neck
and abdomen
but aside from that their entire body is
bulletproof to small arms fire
although they can be killed with 50
caliber ammunition and
explosive bombs and shells and finally
the humans of the future devised a toxin
that can kill them
which means that their cells are still
vulnerable to chemical warfare
and so that's it about the white spikes
from tomorrow wall tell us what you
think about the video
and the aliens in the comments section
below and we want to know what you think
about a comparison between these
creatures
the cinemas and the quiet place death
angel aliens
now we come to the end of the video do
hit that like button for support that
subscribe button to be a part of our
mind cue family
and that bell button for regular updates
on new master videos
right here on minecube till the next one
take care fam